[Musique]
mais dans le débat sur france 24 boris
johnson sera-t-il contraint de partir à
l'étau se resserre autour du premier
ministre britannique visé par deux
enquêtes sur le scandale des fêtes
clandestines au 10 downing street en
plein confinement une enquête
administrative au siège du gouvernement
et une autre policière le chef de
l'opposition travailliste pierre starmer
demandent la démission du premier
ministre boris johnson se défend il
affirme qu'il attend les résultats de
ces enquêtes justement le premier
ministre se focalise sur l'abandon par
l'angleterre de toutes les restrictions
face au co vide 19 mai sur une stratégie
offensive dans la crise de craignent
haine contre la russie alors boris
johnson est il véritablement sur la
sellette en quoi consistent ces fameuses
blues partys comment réagissent les
travaillistes mais aussi les
conservateurs comment le premier
ministre britannique se défend t-il ses
stratégies d'abandon des contraintes
face au co vide en angleterre ou encore
de va-t-en-guerre dans la crise du
crédit elles aideront tel à rester en
place on en débat avec mes invités j'ai
plaisir d'avoir à mes côtés paul
thompson bonsoir vous êtes
vice-président du parti conservateur en
france bienvenue à vous également avec
nous patrick martin géniez à bonsoir
enseignant à sciences po et à l'inalco
spécialiste de l'europe et des relations
internationales
votre dernier livre l'europe at elle un
avenir bienvenue à vous également nous
avons par skype agnès alexandre collier
bonsoir professeur de civilisation un
britannique à l'université de bourgogne
franche comté bienvenue à vous
soir est également duplex de londres de
nice mcshane ancien ministre
travailliste des affaires étrangères
bonsoir de nice mac chaîne bienvenue à
vous également
bonsoir avant de démarrer ce débat on va
écouter bien sûr boris johnson à la
chambre des communes où vous allez le
voir qu'il s'excuse même pour l'une de
ses soirées à laquelle il avait
participé
monsieur le président je tiens à
m'excuser je sais que des millions de
personnes à travers ce pays ont fait des
sacrifices extraordinaires
au cours des 18 derniers mois
je sais la rage qu'ils ressentent envers
moi et envers le gouvernement que je
dirige un garde et bien que je ne puisse
pas anticiper les conclusions de
l'enquêté en cours j'en ai suffisamment
appris pour savoir qu'il ya des choses
que nous n'avons tout simplement pas
bien fait oui ce lit et je doit en
assumer la responsabilité
[Applaudissements]
paul thompson vous qui êtes
vice-président du parti conservateur en
france boris johnson est il sur la
sellette
il se traduit dans ce sens que il est
critique et il est dans une situation
qui est embarrassante c'est certain
je ne pense pas que cela veut dire qu'il
est destiné à acquitter de façon
précipitée ses
responsabilités enfin c'est le sujet du
débat ce soir je pense en tout cas vous
ne pensez pas qu'il va quitter tout de
suite le pouvoir en tout cas johnson
perd le soutien des tories c'est ce qu'à
titre et le conservateur daily telegraph
la presse tout de même conservatrice et
contre lui j'ai vu que le daily mail on
va voir demande si la fête est finie
pour le premier ministre également le
daily mail rats qui parle de parts au
nom de dieu là aussi dont convoite même
qui les a vraiment acculé boris johnson
je peux réagir par rapport à ça oui à
lise le
dans le détail car un jeune ans que je
connais bien qui historiquement soutien
de partis conservateurs c'est à dire il
ya effectivement des avis divergents ils
sont une équipe de commentateurs et
commentatrice certains restent de
fervents partisans partisans de boris
johnson d'autres estiment n'aime pas sa
politique économique d'abord et cette
histoire des fêtes vient l'affaiblir et
se considérait comme bienvenue il il est
affaibli en tout cas vous pourriez dire
ça ce soir boris johnson il il est dans
une certaine difficulté wyss mais c'est
quelqu'un qui a beaucoup de personnalité
et qui est un combattant et m il a dû
faire face avant de repasser dans des
situations très compliquées aussi donc
et il s'en sort toujours aussi juste que
c'est oui jusqu'ici ici alors il s'est
excusé après cette semaine il était
beaucoup plus offensif de nice mcshane
le chef de l'opposition travailliste en
tout cas car ce terme or à demander
carrément lui la démission de boris
johnson il dit que et il pense que les
règles qu'il a fixées ne s'applique pas
à lui même pour vous est-ce qu'il est
sur la sellette
bon on difficulté complètement
maintenant tous les députés
conservateurs tchité il rentre à
la circonscription et mais aussi un
collègue conservateur va parler aux gens
les gens de la rue la spab match grimper
au football ce week-end aux
conseils municipaux qui vont le dire si
vous gardez johnson et les forts
possibles comme à perdre ma position
comme chef de ville et surtout à leurs
militants de base le parti conservateur
h boye en soixante dix ans ils sont
légions correct moyens classiques sont
pas super et à animer mais le
comportement de monsieur johnson je
pense leur choc énorme on est donc c'est
eux qui veulent dire à l'air dépité
parce que c'est pas vraiment la police
hall en quête de holt fonctionnaires
mais c'est le parti conservateur et des
députés qui doivent décider est-ce que
c'est plus dangereux pour le parti de le
garder en poste pendant un moment encore
ou peut-être lui dit poliment comme izia
madame thatcher et des autres premiers
ministres allaient à l'époque vous avez
fait tout ce que vous pouvez faire allez
vous aujourd'hui monnaies vous enfants
on va chercher vos places bros qui n'est
pas qu'il ait pas irriter
donc il est bien sur la sellette tandem
agnès alexandre collier en quoi consiste
pour revenir justement sur le coeur du
problème en quoi consiste t soirée du 10
downing street manifestement il y en a
eu un certain nombre
l'une d'ailleurs pendant laquelle les
convives étaient invités à apporter
leurs boissons brigneau en bout ça fait
vraiment la une de toute la presse
britannique une autre la veille des
funérailles du prince philip alors qu'il
y avait justement ce deuil de la reine
est-ce que ça choque en particulier
parce que c'était pendant le confinement
en plus au royaume uni oui c'est surtout
cette cette dimension qui choque
énormément puisque en fait ce
confinement
a été très mal vécu pendant toute cette
période j'ai vu en angleterre et
effectivement on n'avait pas le droit de
sortir de rencontrer plus d'une personne
les conditions étaient relativement
strictes on pouvait être interrogé par
la police et avoir à se justifier et
boris johnson régulièrement parlait à la
télévision pour expliquer les sacrifices
qui demandait justement aux britanniques
et en particulier le fait de ne pas
pouvoir aller dire au revoir à leurs
proches par exemple à l'hôpital ou en
maison de retraite donc quel quand même
un certain de sacrifice qui a été
demandé de façon presque churchillienne
d'ailleurs par boris johnson pendant
cette période là et on découvre
finalement c'est l'envers du décor que
pendant cette période et en particulier
donc pendant le
le confinement et la veille aussi des
funérailles à des funérailles du prince
philip il y a eu et il est donc c'est
s'est faite à laquelle auquel on imagine
que boris johnson a insisté même s'il
prétend qu'il est resté 10 20 minutes
que c'était des réunions de travail
qu'il ne savait pas et c est donc ce qui
choque peut-être plus les britanniques
c'est à la fois le décalage entre les
sacrifices pour leur a demandé et la
réalité du pouvoir est en même temps
aussi les explications données par boris
johnson qui n'a cessé finalement de se
contredire pour justifier
l'existence de ces fêtes et c'est plus
cette espèce de spirale en fait de
mensonges et de dénégation qui a fini
par effrité là je pense la passion vous
les toniques patrick martin cygnet il ya
une enquête une enquête administrative
avec cette femme dont on parle beaucoup
au royaume uni qui est chargé justement
d'enquêté qui s'appelle sous grez qui
est chargé de sortir ce rapport puis
aussi une enquête policière donc
finalement sous grez ça devient un peu
la bête noire aujourd'hui de boris
johnson oui mais sous grez qui est
certainement quelqu'un de très honnête
est une haute fonctionnaire qui va
rendre son rapport mais c'est un peu
l'arlésienne si vous permettez jusqu'à
présent parce qu'on attend ce soir pas
de rapports toujours pas on l'avait
annoncé en début de semaine puis on l'a
annoncé aux ir et on annonce aujourd'hui
il serait sur le bureau du premier
ministre mais on dit qu'il faut que
boris johnston le lisent avant parce que
il s'est engagé à le publier alors qu'il
avait des rumeurs qui ne le lirai avant
de publier donc il ya ce problème le
second problème c'est une enquête de
police et on a dit comme un map comment
à premier ministre qui passe son temps à
mentir depuis le début du bric site
jusqu'à maintenant peut-il prêté serment
devant la police qui valait l'interrogé
pas et c'est de la grosse difficulté
aujourd'hui toutes les enquêtes
effectivement son fait mais tout est
fait pour éviter la vérité je veux dire
la vérité que la vérité éclate
est on en train de dire oui bah si beau
jason a menti il paiera une amende comme
tout le monde mais on est quand même
dans un système politique que si le
premier ministre n'a pas respecté les
règles mais bien moralement sa
réputation c'est fini vous rendez compte
qu'à la veille des obsèques du prince il
était en train de faire la fête aux
tanins une stricte bon et enfin des
rumeurs disent que des photos arriverait
directement sur le bureau de son gré
pour bien montrer que boris johnson
était bien présent lors de ces
garden-party thompson pourquoi toujours
pas de rapport le rapport de soubré
devait sortir d'ailleurs ce jeudi
peut-être demain enfin en tout cas ça
devait être cette semaine je ne peux pas
vous fournir une explication là dessus
je pose la question à mes gars ça lui
fait gagner un peu de temps ce qu'est la
tonne comme vous avez justement d une
haute fonctionnaire c'est une femme qui
a une trempe reconnu par parle tout le
monde en même temps la redoute un peu
j'ai lu boris johnson
c'est quelqu'un qui a beaucoup d
influence
sont utiles dans la vie politique depuis
de longues années parce que parlons
c'est un cas beaucoup de carleton très
intelligente et
sait comment fonctionne le système
mais je pense que le rapport va quand
même sortir et c'est inconcevable que ce
soit dans dix ans ou 15 ans mais si ce
rapport dit que effectivement boris
johnson était à ces soirées
qu'effectivement il a participé à
l'organisation
est-ce que qu'est ce qu'il va faire il
devrait quitter le pouvoir dans ce cas
est-ce qu'il y aura une motion de
défiance de la part des conservateurs
c'est possible je
suppose que non je suppose que nos deux
les ennemis de boris johnson
estime qu' il devrait partir mais ils ne
l'ont jamais ils ont toujours détesté
ils n'ont pas aimé sa politique sur le
break site et donc pour c'est une
occasion en or pour essayer de descendre
en ce qui concerne le parti conservateur
se disent à votre question à il ya
certaines personnes qui estiment qu'il a
une politique trop centriste même trop à
gauche et qui sont réservées à son sujet
mais à je tends à penser que ses
qualités de deux leaders qui se
parlaient au public et ce n'est pas du
tout vrai que c'est quelqu'un qui ment
tout le temps
avez-vous dit qu'il ne ment pas tout il
ya un disque odile un disque de vérité
sur deux précise également sera sur la
situation de de ceux sur l'idée
d'indépendance du roi munich pourrait il
il donne suite à ses idées et les
électeurs roduit en savent gré donc donc
baissé dans sa cote de jeu vous fait
intervenir tout de suite patrick martin
génie mais tout d'abord dennis mcshane
que vous répondiez justement à paul
thompson il a tout de même à coup dans
l'aisne me semble-t-il en termes de
popularité boris johnson en ce moment
ils se nourrissent de sondages ne sont
pas bons
a
servi a servi la droite il a servi
rupert murdoch 1 il a menti en ce sens
où quand il ya une faute avec un beau
d'annoncer le report sine die oui bonne
chose mais on va rester dans le marché
unique et deux jours après le vote pour
quitter l'union des traités posture le
seul un grand papier dans le daily
telegraph
mais on va rester dans le marché unique
le problème on est comme a dit sylvie
bermann ambassadrice très très chevronné
la france l'angleterre au moment du
référendum boychuk et je la cite c'est
pas mes propos est montrent un invétéré
demandé à ses femmes ses petites amies à
ça c'est parti c'est coliposte lilhac
soleil dans le monde bolt c'est boris
johnson et maintenant on peut monter à
sa femme à ses amis à son parti mais
c'est pas ça qui va les écouter son boss
par le droit à l'angleterre leleu aurait
six mois aura pas le droit à
l'angleterre demont tiers au parlement
et paul johnson a dit noir sur blanc non
il n'y avait pas des fêtes à downing
street du tout et marne on l'a et vidéos
sûrement avons un vingtaine pour c'est
ça son problème c'est pourquoi c'est
pourquoi la police maintenant jamais vu
avant imaginez la plice arrive au 1
devant président macro pour deux modèles
un grondement des colts quelque chose
qui s'est passé analysé s'est jamais vu
en angleterre
justement c'est inconcevable maintenant
la question qui est le plus important à
qui dois faire il fait trembler
bourriche je crois alors ça me faire
trembler boris attendait mark martin
patrick martin genia lisi a réalisé très
clairement plus personne ne fait
confiance à boris johnson comme il ya
deux d'hédonisme adsense est un menteur
invétéré il a toujours menti il a même
dit qu'il ne voulait plus respecter les
traités internationaux et donc sur ceux
pouvant pas ça qui va le non non non
lorsque en parlant du parti conservateur
je passe sous le contrôle de nos amis
britannique margaret thatcher elle est
partie dans des conditions similaires
madame teresa main et partie pourquoi
parce que vous avez au sein de votre
parti ce qu'on appelle le comité 1922
qui à tout moment qui regroupe les
députés de base du parti conservateur et
qui à tout moment peuvent dire au
premier ministre par t alors il y à une
motion de censure qui est possible à
condition que 54 lettres de députés
arrivent au comité pour organiser un
vote est aujourd'hui très clairement les
députés certains n'ont pas encore fait
ce pas décrire ce courrier sans quoi le
comité sera obligé de prendre une motion
de censure premièrement mais imaginez
tous ses députés conservateurs qui ont
été élus dans la vague il y a deux ans
dans la vague conservatrice avec une
majorité énorme depuis entre 80 et 100
députés tous ces députés qui ont été
élus dans les anciennes circonscriptions
travaillistes
ce sont des gens qui s'y de mam il y
avait des élections seraient balayés par
les électeurs donc il ya aujourd'hui une
crise très grave qui montre aussi que le
parti travailliste est entre 10 et 15%
plus haut que le parti conservateur s'il
y avait des élections législatives et ça
les parts le parti doit le prendre en
compte pour analyser la situation toile
comme sony pourrait effectivement s'il
enquête révèle qu'effectivement il a
menti ce qui est une possibilité il
enquête policière est ce qu'il pourrait
justement faire l'objet de cette ve vote
de défiance dont on vient de parler
patrick martin géniez c'est à dire
effectivement ce comité 1922 qui a été
fondée formé de 18 députés conservateurs
se passera sous votre contrôle qui
enverrait qui peut envoyer lorsqu'il ya
15% donc des députés conservateurs
envoie une lettre l'aide de défiance
justement pour que boris johnson quitte
le pouvoir il mettre quelqu'un d'autre
du parti conservateur le système veut
que s'il ya le nombre requis de l'être
il faut organiser à un nouveau
procès dure de deux choix du leader du
parti quand du parti et et un celui qui
est en place peut se présenter aussi
mais il sera obligé de faire face à un
combat de ce type et bonne chance je
crois a déjà dit que ce temps une telle
éventualité
il se présenterait et puis on ils l'ont
très bien comment
dans ce cas il doit rester pendant un an
c'est ça à son poste au moins je pense
qu'il est reconfirmer dans la haie et
mais il n'y a pas des 54 restent
en vous disant vous en être sûr mais
sinon j'ai l'air de l'être humain même
temps dans ma peau neuve mais s'il
enquête montre qu'il a menti il y en
aura peut-être plus s'il a menti au
parlement il sera obligé de partir
vous pensez cela
[Musique]
il faudra voir les circonstances parce
que il ya des questions quand même et il
se trouve que je suis juriste il y à des
questions de droit et des questions de
fait il a des questions de
caractérisation il y avait une
intéressante contribution dans le daily
telegraph deux
intellectuels conservateurs britanniques
est un député européen voyez est selon
lui et il y avait eu des défaites ne
s'était en fait entre collègues qui à la
fin de la journée donc des gens qui de
toute façon son ensemble longue de
journée en train de travailler et qu'on
fait en fait des distinctions et a fait
tout à fait non le prince est que
c'était des gens qui étaient ensemble
tout à longueur de journée et après ils
sont partis dans le jardin pour
reprendre quelques heures donc des deux
ans c'est assez différent que
d'organiser une fête
dans une boîte ou chez soi où on invite
les gens de l'extérieur brice mach
chaîne rigole mais avant vous faire
réagir à nouveau agnès alexandre collier
est ce qu effectivement il pourrait y
avoir une sorte de fronde conservatrices
contre boris johnson votre analyse oui
on pourrait peut-être revenir sur la
procédure pour préciser un peu avoue
téléspectateurs au fait ce qui peut se
passer donc on a évoqué le fait qu' il
faudrait 54 lettres de députés
conservateurs pour déclencher un vote de
défiance
et si le vote de défiance a lieu il faut
que boris johnson remporte la majorité
en fait des voix c'est à dire à peu près
180 voix pour rester au pouvoir si c'est
pas le cas il y aura effectivement une
élection du leadership à laquelle ne
pourra pas se présenter mais si
effectivement il reste pouvoir là en
l'occurrence comme vous l'avez rappelé
il n'y aura pas de vote de confiance de
vote de défiance pendant pendant un an
donc ça c'est peut-être le premier point
pour préciser
et le votre question excusez moi la
question parce qu'effectivement il
risque de subir cela à l'issue de l'anc
est ce fameux comité 1922 est ce qu on
est proche cette année 54
conservateurs pour fait pour l'instant
brady qui
dirige le comité 1922 tient cette
information secrète alors on a
effectivement des rumeurs je crois que
samedi il y avait une trentaine de
courriers qui avaient été envoyés mais
tout ça ce sont des rumeurs
effectivement on en saura plus quand le
chiffre sera franchie style et s'il est
franchi
ce qu'on sait c'est qu'il ya eu alors il
ya eu des pressions qui ont été exercées
pour un pour essayer de convaincre les
députés mais ça c'est un classique
finalement de la vie parlementaire
britannique puisqu'il ya ce qu'on
appelle des whips qui exercent
régulièrement des pressions sur sur les
députés rebelles des dix matches et que
vous vous étiez en train de rire à
écouter justement paul thompson lorsque
il parlait
cette personne qui faisait des
distinctions entre soirées organisées ou
pas vraiment organiser
ça vous semble pas le le monsieur s'est
élancé de la pole position samedi puis
de 15 ans le nôtre allonnes ses grands
amis à moi on fait des skis ensemble
mais franchement à 7 ans pelouse à doite
plus réactionnaires que eric zemmour
eric zemmour son truc au schiste par
rapport à daniel donc je suis dire mon
cher collègue britannique je vous en
prie ne s'était pas d'un dernier un
homme a comme témoin pour votre cause
non aoc c'est clair c'est net que
y'avait des fêtes cette erreur ne
grandira qui a commis boris johnson
c'est de ne pas l'avouer tout de suite
peut-être virer quelques responsables
qui est organisée c'est fait mais il a
menti à la chambre des communes et ça
c'est le crime impardonnable n'a pas de
constitution
chez nous on a pas moyen
pour se débarrasser d'un prémunissent le
peuple sait que le parti et les députés
d'une partie qui peut le faire et le
bas' depuis deux siècles c'est qu'on ne
m'ont jamais au parlement donc ça c'est
ses voiles à découvrir c'est moi c'est
vous que c'est pas moi qui le dit
forcément
co2 360 députés conservateurs qui
doivent décider
ce week-end c'est très important on n'a
pas l'impression regardant la télévision
je relis dans toute la presse qu' il ya
un mouvement faveur de monsieur johnson
de cette façon il a servi il a fait tout
ce qu'il peut faire c'est à dire sortir
l'angleterre obligé break 6 e trudeau
que chaque jour sur vesle d'être plus
d'un jean paul
pays est maintenant mieux vaut quelqu'un
plus calme moins excité un peu plus
normale qui est toujours
marié à la femme qu'il a épousée au
début quelques uns un peu plus normale à
premier ministre
nomade oui un peu de normalité s'il vous
plaît patrick martin legner vous lirez à
giral en tout cas enrichissent una car
le ministre l'économie et cité comme un
des successeurs potentiels lice trustent
également la mise des affaires
étrangères qui est une très forte
briques site euse également nommé ça se
bouscule tout de même au portillon et
des conservateurs ça se bouscule au
portillon même si tout le monde
officiellement des nous sommes
totalement solidaires de boris johnson
bien sûr nous le soutenons mais
lorsqu'on suit à peu la vie
institutionnelle britannique on
s'aperçoit que ce gouvernement est
complètement paralysée par cette affaire
il ne travaille plus les hauts
fonctionnaires sont très inquiets le
parlement il ya eu hier ou avant-hier
s'est séparé à 17 heures et il ya donc
on voit à boris johnson qui est
complètement calfeutrés dans le tarn
street et pillant vous disiez il ya des
députés le nombre de 54 lettres n'a
peut-être pas été atteint mais il y à
des accusations graves qui sont portées
contre le cabinet de boris johnson au
terme desquelles des députés sur piret
de terribles pressions soient à sortir
des affaires contre dans la presse
certains ont dit nous n'investirons plus
dans vos circonscriptions pour
construire des écoles alors que madame
bien dire effectivement il ya un oui pia
chef de la majorité parlementaire qui
dit si vous êtes si vous ne souhaitez
pas le premier ministre on ne vous
soutiendra pas lors des prochaines
élections mais des accusations du style
nous n'investirons plus dans vos
circonscriptions c'est très grave et la
presse est en train d'enquêter sur ce
point donc on voit bien que boris
johnson essaye de contre attaquer très
méchamment contre ces parlementaires ce
qui est peut être un frein effectivement
à cette rébellion ont peut-être une
autre façon de contre-attaqué c'est de
faire de l'angleterre le premier pays à
abandonner toutes les restrictions face
au co vide 19 le port du masque n'est
plus obligatoire en angleterre il
revendique ce vent de liberté boris
johnson la famille isolement également
pour les cas positifs peut-être pour le
mois de mars on écoute
à partir de maintenant le gouvernement
ne demande plus aux gens de travailler à
domicile
et les gens devraient désormais parler à
leurs employeurs des dispositions à
prendre pour retourner au bureau
après avoir examiné attentivement les
données le cabinet a conclu qu'une fois
que ces règles auront expiré le
gouvernement n'imposera plus le port du
masque où que ce soit
olten s'est aussi un peu nul à une
manière de faire diversion d'avoir une
sorte de deux socles qui vous soutient
que d'annoncer ce type de mesure en ce
moment pour boris johnson le vent de
liberté
d'abord bien sûr et l'essai de
contracter que c'est parfaitement normal
et légitime un premier ministre attaque
et n'a pas un devoir de ne rien dire de
ne pas réagir donc un ou des
moyens tous les moyens sont aussi vous
justifier non bien sûr que non
je ne crois pas non plus qu un
immobilisme ou un blocage des rouages du
gouvernement je ne sais pas du tout où
vous trouvez ça
le contraire le pays est très actif sur
le front de la gestion du coc vide
également en politique internationale
est là aussi si on veut à tout prix
critique et boris johnson on peut dire
oui
ils montent au créneau à part bord
l'ukraine pour faire diversion ce serait
oublier que la la les gouvernements
successifs britannique depuis depuis
toujours je dirais
sont très vigilants par rapport la
russie ils ont tendance à être hostile à
la hausse il on va revenir sur l'ukraine
mais sur le coup vide justement parce
qu'elle a beaucoup reproché à boris
johnson d'avoir une opinion différente
d'avoir fait volte-face à plusieurs
reprises sur cette épidémie est
aujourd'hui le fait qu'ils annoncent la
fin du port du masque la limitation
justement la fin de ces restrictions ça
le rend populaire c'est populaire au
royaume uni en angleterre c'est auprès
d'eux
de ce nombre de personnes certainement
c'est un sujet qui qui est quand même
compliquée il ya des débats en france en
allemagne aux pays bas et
c'est vrai qu aurait muni il y a eu des
oscillations assez violente dans la
politique du gouvernement plus qu'en
france plus qu'en france je dirais et
même il c'est vrai aussi que au royaume
uni mon impression en tout cas et que
l'opinion publique pousse davantage pour
se débarrasser de ces restes russe et
l'inspection de nice mcshane est-ce que
effectivement il fait un peu diversion
la boris johnson en a en annonçant
l'abandon de ces mesures je suis chargé
non mes excuses et bois
a conforté ce que nos sports et la
réalité je suis arrivé ici au studio de
the boss tu le monde pour dom des
masques jeu je prends le métro demain tu
ne m'en porte des masques aujourd'hui
dans un si beau mais ce n'est pas
obligatoire pour des masques non c'est
pas c'est plus légalement obligatoire
mais le plus bas des médecins a passé
son sol téléviseur allione tous les
jours 10 on brûle aux précautions direct
des écoles non non non non non on va pas
risquer encore quand il faut fermer nos
masses pourquoi parce que monsieur paul
jones me donner un cadeau à la droite
libertaire ont-ils vax est donc un jeu
m'excuse mais je suis pas convaincu ma
voix je suis par contre ce que bastien
annoncé surtout pour les voyageurs
arrivant ici sans oublier l obligation d
un prochain point un test pcr mais quand
même le peuple ont beaucoup plus de
sagesse parce qu'on à 105 ans 4000
milles marins britanniques qui sont
morts morts parce qu'au début
monsieur jones et là c'est mal organisé
les ehpad
le matériel de promotion
on a vu tomber des vieux hommes plus de
90 ans mort on sent ce dernier cas là
avec le petit nouveau grâce à la
compétence de la gestion donc oui on a
fait un beau programme de vaccination je
sache je donne mes skis mais c'est ce
qui met en avant bien sûr 8le le
programme de vaccination mais mombay
mais les médecins les médecins les
coastal déjà fait cet
hôte et l'obligation de porter des
masques il y a quelques jours donc mais
si johnson fait de catch up mais je ne
pense pas que ça va changer d'un iota
ce que le peuple italique pour c'est
surtout ce que ces députés pons à ça ça
va être défini ce week-end pas ce que
leurs supporteurs bélie tôt leurs amis
leurs électeurs vont leur petit ça sympa
le week-end pour les dangers écoutez
denis macshane alex agnès alexandre
collier est-ce que vous avez
l'impression tout de même qu'en
annonçant ces mesures
aujourd'hui boris johnson veut se
focaliser sur la relance de l'économie
et sur une sorte de retour à la vie
normale
oui bien sûr d'ailleurs la presse a
appelé ça l'opération viandes rouges
jouissent à ronger c'est à dire faire
diversion en annonçant toutes sortes de
mesures
pour détourner l'attention des
britanniques donc il ya la levée des
restrictions il ya eu aussi la
déclaration sur la fin de la redevance
pour la bbc qui devrait être terminée
mais bon tout ça ce sont effectivement
des promesses et des annonces qui sont
qui sont censées apaiser la situation et
gagner du temps et en particulier il ya
effectivement ses promesses
d'investissements dans les fameux
bastion du raid walk on a évoqué en
début d'émission qui sont ces 55 sièges
conquis par de nouveaux députés
conservateurs
entre les médecins et le nord-est qu'il
a actuellement comme l'a rappelé danis
nations doivent rendre des comptes à
leurs électeurs d'une part n'y a pas eu
de promesse d'investissements qui ont
été tenus et est en plus effectivement
il ya toute cette situation de scandales
qui qui doit
certainement augmenter la gronde et des
électeurs dans ses bastions très fragile
puisque ils ont été arrachés aux
travaillistes qui peuvent retourner dans
le camp travail est ce assez facilement
en 2024 aux prochaines élections donc on
est quand même situation très fragile
pour le moment oui comme ça il y réagir
oui peut-être vous encensez députés en
ce qui concerne les députés du duvet
d'oie recommandé exactement ce dont part
de madame
oui exactement oui
au cours langlet a c'est vrai
qu'actuellement de la situation volatil
mais vous avez bien fait de remarquer
que les prochaines élections c'est en
2024 à des élections anticipées mais
c'est très peu probable parce qu'il ya
une forte majorité britanniques je
voudrais rappeler que
à l'époque des gilet jaune en france
beaucoup de il va beaucoup de sympathie
pour les prix gilet jaune assez
largement réparties dans un premier
temps
la réaction de emmanuel macron été vus a
demandé à ces critiques beaucoup de gens
y conflit d'aider des classes aisées
après ça évolue et pourquoi ce que
j'évoque ça simplement pour dire que on
est on se trouve au coeur d'un épisode
certain qu'ils détestent pour
l'assurance d'une voiture mais ça ne
fait que prouver que c'est il ne fait
que mentir il ne fait que ça une façon
c'est une image très courte de la
personne et c'est exactement et et je
pense que la situation peut simplement
se calmer et on passera à autre chose
oui il est attaqué sur la gauche mais
est également attaquée sur la droite
rappelez-vous le l'ancien ministre du
bric site qui vient de démissionner je
crois que c'est david frost fait pas
d'erreur il vient de démissionner parce
qu'il reproche à boris johnson
d'augmenter des impôts de ne pas avoir
respecté sa parole et ils exigent du
premier ministre une diminution des
impôts et de retrouver une vraie
politique de droite et donc on voit bien
qu'il est tiraillé
sur sa droite et sur sa gauche et david
frost serait quant à lui un éventuel
candidat à la succession de boris
johnson et alors qu'en disent les
travaillistes donné ce mac shane j'ai
franchement le nouveau patron des
travaillistes on a un peu appris à le
connaître ces dernières semaines parce
qu'on l'avait un peu oublié ce parti
travailliste qui était vraiment en
lambeaux on peut le dire il ya quelques
mois de nice mcshane et puis tout d'un
coup on le voit effectivement à la
chambre des communes est ce que il y a
une opportunité aujourd'hui pour le
parti travailliste
oui bien sûr on est en train de ce repas
tiers après deux rondes de rester dans
les oubliettes des cas des gens a
totalement inédit bannalec table comme
jeremy cabine à savon cela jérôme cirque
est amassé un avocat modéré so so so so
le triste et il faut jamais oublier que
chez nous on dit que l'opposition ne
gagne jamais eu d'élections c'est
toujours le gouvernement qu'il le perde
et moi j'étais député de 1 de ses red
bull ça de ces régions de l'armure rouge
derrière
luis et les os ya site sidérurgique
mines industrielles classe ouvrière et
on voit déjà des infections par exemple
des cityens elle a promis un train tgv
en vitesse pour le nord-est et le mythe
l'insee les yorkshire newcastle il a
terminé il va imposer à augmenter un
homme pauvre space propre et pour le
sécurité sociale propice pour son a7
prin tôt donc je crois en à l'inflation
qui g très très sérieusement donc je
crois c'est le bon moment pour monsieur
johnson de dire oui je fais je vous
contribuerez à l'histoire de
l'angleterre ont coupé tous les liens
avec l'europe maintenant je vais aller
je m'occupais après soixante haut de mes
deux bébés je vais écrire je vais faire
des discours je vais gagner beaucoup de
temps et de son chien et je laisse
sociale
jerry chéries-chéris le travail cela
veut dire
passer paul thompson j'imagine en tout
cas boris johnson il tient justement à
ce global britton puisque vous en
parliez il ya un instant danis mcshane
on va l'écouter justement sur l'ukraine
c'est vrai qu'il était vente va t'en
guerre depuis le début de la semaine et
sur cette question ukrainienne boris
johnson on l'écouté
les ukrainiens ont tout à fait le droit
moral et légal de défendre leur pays et
je crois que leur résistance serait
féroce et tenace et que l'effusion de
sang serait comparable monsieur le
président à la première guerre en
tchétchénie ou en bosnie et fois tout
autre conflit que l'europe enduré depuis
personne ne sortirait gagnant d'une
telle catastrophe
je me sens un petit peu car ce loupé
agnès alexandre collier là c'était
vraiment pour le coup celui qui veut
montrer que globaux britten existants
restent à l'international
oui tout à fait c'est s'il ya bien une
image ou une personnalité qui peut
sauver
cette image qu'il a là qu'il a essayé de
vendre en 2010 note de l'homme fort de
la situation un homme fort du breakbeat
et l'homme fort sur la scène
internationale donc encore une fois à
mes yeux ça fait partie bon d'une part
des affaires courantes du gouvernement
et puis de 7,7 voilà capacités aussi à
détourner l'attention
mais est-ce que ce sera suffisant pour
le maintenir au pouvoir je ne crois pas
je voudrais simplement revenir sur un
point qui a été évoquée par un nouveau à
nouveau invités font pas que des vitres
us soit un des successeurs potentiels de
me paraît impossible ce qui les lords il
n'est pas il n'est pas élu en revanche
on peut parler des deux successeurs
potentiels de train pour en tout cas des
deux challengers potentiels qui sont
régis unac et élise chaussée qui comme
l'a rappelé votre invité effectivement
viennent plutôt de la droite du parti
donc là actuellement ça confirme bien
l'idée qu' il est pris en tenaille entre
différentes factions ce soit la gauche
la droite et qu' il est dans une
position
difficile un
intégriste oui patrick maître martin
génie en tout cas c'est vrai que il a
montré que les européens étaient divisés
sur cette question de l'ukrainien a
profité voilà alors pour être totalement
honnête effectivement c'est une position
qu'il peut tenir le royaume uni a
toujours été de très bon élève des états
unis et il est vrai qu'en plus le
royaume uni c'est une grande puissance
membres du conseil de sécurité des
nations unies et donc c'est vrai qu'il
peut apporter des troupes et ce qu'il a
fait il a su enfoncer un coin dans les
alliés européens à savoir et bien
montrer qu'il y avait une vraie division
parmi l'europe et il l'a dit il
semblerait que nos amis allemands soient
très timide sur ce point il n'a pas tort
car l'allemagne s'est ridiculisée hier
en proposant l'envoi de 5000 casques à
pour protéger la population à kiev ce
que le maire de kiev a considéré comme
étant une véritable farce donc là
effectivement c'est un point fort du
royaume uni qui reste qu'une puissance
militaire très importante il ne reste
pas mois que le fait de d'agréger la
population lorsqu'il ya risque nationale
et un risque de guerre c'est aussi pour
lui une façon et bien de reconquérir une
sorte de stature qu'il a perdu et on
conclure ce débat paul thompson alors il
parle il part pas non je pense qu'il va
rester parce que je montre mon analyse
c'est que les députés à se dire on s'est
quand même quelqu'un qui sait gagner des
hug des élections qui a beaucoup de
charisme et qui est et qui
arrive bien communiquer certains jours
le déteste mais il a quand même il n'y a
pas de remplaçants dudu du même niveau
et je pense qu'ils se diront on autant
rester avec un gagnant et on à londres à
la suite de ce match et ils parient papa
j'ai collé je connais j'ai connu boris
type oui bah vingt cinq ans on n'est pas
de grands amis connaissances aurait dîné
en saut j'ai écrit posso ces journaux le
dernier conversation était très amicale
très positive donc cette norme ne
m'avait beaucoup d'humour c'est une
espèce de mouche dans notre vie
politique inouï nous fait rire et dans
le calme on y
lit peut nous faire rire mais il doit
dire la vérité à la chambre des communes
un peu excusez moi ces spécialistes dans
des fosses bolton séduit le nomme les
effectifs de l'armée britannique à 60000
c'était derrière moi qu'on a en prison
en l'envoyant douzaine d entraîneur pour
utiliser les missiles antichars je suis
très content qu'on a fait ça et tu n'es
pas dit ce que les cyniques 10 mai mais
ce qu'il va exécuter la plus tendance
mcshane c'était juste un peu à une sorte
de pronostic je vous faisais faire il ne
part pas
être honnête je pense qu'il arrive à la
fin c'est ici la fin s et c'est ce week
end ses proches et jo je ne sais pas
vous mais j'ai osé rare que paulson ce
sera la prochaine élection merci
beaucoup d'aces mcshea merci à vous paul
thompson merci alex alias alexandre
collier d'avoir été avec nous également
et merci à vous patrick martin géniez
merci à vous tous nous avons subi reste
avec nous sur france 24